well welcome back our next guest is a
former MEP whose years in the European
Parliament merely strengthened his your
skepticism and a former chair of the
European research group of that venture
Conservative MPs how it's best known
though for his dodgy dad jokes on
Twitter joining us now is the brexit
Minister Chris Heaton Harris thank you
very much for being with us it feels
like it's a bit of a strange week to be
interviewing you because it feels kind
of Groundhog Day Theresa May is going
back to Brussels again to ask for more
air concessions that MPs have voted
again against the government serve
brexit plan and we embrace it
purgatory hit yeah I think it can feel
like that sometimes and certainly in
Parliament it does feel I mean the the
words groundhog and day are mentioned in
just about every speech and have been
since the beginning of January but there
is actually a process and and there is a
definite plan I mean Parliament has made
up its mind on a couple of things one
voted to activate article 50 so we are
leaving the European Union on the 29th
of March the second and that does mean
actually that if we do not have a
negotiated deal then we leave with a
thousand a Gaucher to deal on the 29th
of March the second is the only positive
thing that Parliament's voted for was an
amendment by the chairman of the 1922
committee so Graham Brady which is where
actually a number of people the whole
Conservative Party the DUP and indeed
lots of Labour MPs came together to say
that they want changes to the backstop
and then they could vote for the Prime
Minister see this is the problem though
isn't it you say you want you can just
leave a backstop but this is a two-way
negotiation Brussels peace has been
absolutely hardline on this and even
your own concerted colleague Steve Baker
said the negotiations are a complete
waste of time so we need to linked
what's that messages in The Sunday Times
yeah so III don't think we could
negotiate and so a complete waste of
time that's good and you know there's
there's a huge amount of activity as you
see the Prime Minister's going up see
present Younker the my my boss the
sexual state in the depart for exiting
the European Union Steve Barclay is out
there tomorrow the Attorney General's
going out to Brussels on Tuesday there
is a huge amount of activity on this and
there's also a huge amount of noise
coming in from individual member states
into the European Commission because
actually everybody wants to have a deal
the same time though we're talking about
Groundhog Day and this continued
uncertainty is having an impact I can
understand why the government might want
to run the clock down but it's having an
impact for businesses we can have a look
for example at what fly BMI said in
their statement explaining the reasons
for going into administration
they said current trading and future
prospects have also been seriously
affected by the uncertainty created by
the brexit process which has led to our
inability to secure valuable trying
contracts in Europe I mean this is
starting to have a real-world impact now
so the government is not trying to run
the clock down the government is trying
to get a negotiated deal with our
European partners we've put that to the
vote in the House of Commons in January
it did not pass the House of Commons has
decided what it would like to see which
is the Brady amendment that I mentioned
not so long ago so why are you speeding
things up I mean 100 MPs are going on
holiday next week because as you rightly
said we are negotiating with another
group of people we're not just
negotiating with ourselves as some
people seem to think we are actually in
a very broad negotiation with our
European partners we've focused on what
Parliament believes is the right thing
to focus on and that's where we're
trying to get the deal nailed down I'm
Teresa Mays written T conservative MPs
and today pretty stone ly worded letter
she's saying history will judge us all
for the parts we've played in this
process if you carry on in the same vein
as you are now how do you think history
will judge the Conservatives well
history is going to judge the
Conservative Party for getting
delivering on the referendum result that
the British people voted for in massive
number seventeen point four million
people voted to leave the European Union
and will be judged because we will
deliver on that there's also a huge
number of Labour MPs will be delivering
on that to the confusion that exists
more than anything is confusion as to
what Labor's policy is I mean like they
seem to not particularly know it as
they've had to try and clarify it to you
now whether they want to actually help
get a deal over the line that actually
if you identify the arguments within the
letter that Jeremy Corbyn sent to the
prime minister he's basically saying we
quite like your deal we just can't vote
for it because politics is too important
you offered a permanent customs union
labor would vote for you but a permanent
customs union is actually staying within
the European Union we all staying within
it might not be the kind of brexit that
you want to see but it's not so labor
set themselves six tests for what brexit
should look like
that's yeah they do like chopping and
changing I dunno but one of those tests
is actually impossible to fulfill so you
know they'd they've got a bit of a
debate going on and out there party I'm
not discuss guys that we haven't in the
Conservative Party but the government's
position is to get this over the line a
negotiated deal on the by the 29th of
what as soon as possible and we've got a
lot of work to do working in Brussels
this week huge amount of effort going in
to get this deal you can see why trees
may might be a bit nervous though
relying on her own back benches to
support her deal when you see what's
happened this week when conserved enough
conservative conservative MPs voted
against her approach which meant that
she lost that vote I mean it's
embarrassing isn't when bottles look at
that are you frustrated as a former
chair of the European research group
it's how some of your colleagues have
been patient no no I'd like to think I'm
one of the most pedantic you're a
skeptics you'll find in Parliament and I
can understand how some people really do
worry about the detail of everything but
this week's essentially what happened in
in last last week is that Parliament
decided to vote on for nothing so we go
back to what we voted for for and as I
said at the very top of the interview
and we voted to activate article 52
leave the European Union on the 29th of
March and the one plan that Parliament
has come behind that there is a majority
for its demonstratable demonstrably so
was the government's felt that further
sloppily worded motion um no no no I
don't think so actually I think people
in this heightened sense if these
amazingly heightened political times of
excitement or whatever you can
understand on a non-binding motion that
people want to demonstrate that they are
still wanting to have their views heard
and now I mean we talked a bit about
divisions in labor there's clearly
divisions on the conservative bunch as
well I just want to picture what one of
your ministerial colleagues said in an
interview this week
this is Richard Harrington the business
minister and he said talking about the
European research group I read that
Nigel Farraj is setting up a new party
called brexit and if I were them I'd be
looking at that in my view they're not
conservatives see right now
no but Richard is right so I love
Richard Harrington he's one of the best
ministers he's actually I know deal
minister in the in the Department of for
business and he's helping me I'm the no
deal minister in the brexit Department
trying to coordinate our approach to no
deal and he's helping me tremendously to
get this but we both have we all have
one singular objective which is to get a
negotiated deal so we don't have to go
down the path of no deal whatsoever how
bad would no deal be um well it's be
suboptimal it's nowhere near the scare
story level what that means of optimal
what means not optimal you know
essentially a deal would be much better
for the country to deliver certainty
quicker and it's what businesses are
asking for what employers in my
constituency and across the country are
asking for and you know I think I'm with
the people of Derby who are on your clip
earlier you know people just want this
thing done they want brexit delivered
they want their voices heard and that
and the referendum result delivered upon
and that's what we're going to do now
you've got into some hot water in the
past no for right into universities
asking them for a list of the names of
tutors who are teaching students about
brexit and what they were teaching them
about now at the time your colleague Joe
Johnson said it was right it was because
you were researching a book how's the
book coming yeah well well I'm on the
picture bit now so I'm ready to color
those in no so I know it's in the book
well might be a book one day but it
won't be about that so I wrote to
universities because I'm interested in
brexit I was a member of the European
Parliament for 10 years I formed the I
was chairman of the European research
group first six and a half I formed the
Fresh Start project about a
renegotiation with our European partners
I was a whip at the time and I just
wanted to find out what other people
were saying about brexit I may be why
some people might have thought it was
you know I may be English isn't my top
subject and maybe it was a comment he
worded letter but I actually just wanted
and most universities took a beginning
took it in the light it was written and
some contacted me to say all sort of
stuff you want and this is our reading
list and all this and I didn't comment
at the time because I was whipped and
you know if I upset anybody I apologize
okay now just finally Donald Trump's
called on the UK to take back Islamic
state fighters should the UK be taking
them back well I mean the government's
primary objective is to so I don't
disagree with what Lord Dennett said on
your on your previous piece but the
government's primary objective is to
make sure our nation is safe and secure
and we do have a statute book that can
properly police and make sure these
people coming back that they will
undoubtedly be talked to possibly
arrested and charged with various crimes
we've just updated we just issued they
come back as international more stands
they can come back I don't think my
constituents to be very comfortable with
it
okay thank you very much Christine
Harris